Let's now have a look at the object oriented architecture style and
its relationship to maintainability.
The object oriented architecture style is a very powerful way of
organizing a system.
And maintainability is significantly increased when using this style,
because of the independence of the components, both their encapsulated data and
the hands-off, message passing style of interaction.
On the other hand, objects will have to refer to each other.
Okay? There needs to be some way of identifying other objects in the system.
This can increase the intercomponent dependencies,
thereby reducing maintainability.